[Music]
welcome back everyone to my analysis of
hunter hunter a series that's educated
me on some of life's most valuable
lessons
introducing questions that have echoed
and reverberated in my mind for literal
weeks
questions like should we seek answers to
mysteries that will hurt us
can we redeem ourselves after horrendous
acts and did you know that bungy gum has
the properties of both rubber and gum
with each question more resonant and
profound than the last weaving a
tapestry of a series that has deeply
impressed me
welcome everyone back to my blind review
of the hunter hunter manga and this
week's gonna be a
doozy as i tackle the first half of this
fabled arc
discussing some of the most adult and
mature subject matters i think i've ever
discussed on this channel concerning
shonen this section masterfully talked
to my heartstrings and bonded me to its
main character in ways i've never
felt before this is gonna be a tough one
folks so
everyone thank you for joining me
because today i'll be discussing the
mature tale of some young men making
their way to york new city and the dark
underworld that resides there i'm
totally not mark and this is my blind
review of hunter hunter's
york new city arc this story is
bananas and despite this video covering
half of the arc
within the first few chapters it
cemented itself as the strongest of the
series that i've seen thus far
taking the emotional moments from the
first arc and action from the second
and third to produce something truly
unique and powerful this is a story that
at least to me
seems to have something that it wants to
say something that i'm honestly not too
used to being taken seriously in these
types of stories
realistic family trouble and the trauma
that may sprout from it
interestingly for the first time in the
story instead of following one linear
path or plot thread from the point of
view of gon
we follow two points of view with a
couple of other secondary threats
and surprisingly in this section
kurapika assumes the leading man role
in his plot thread during this section
of york new city's arc
and it's amazing but structurally
speaking i'm a massive fan of the way
this particular arc is structured and
stories that are structured this way
because it often ends up building
momentum when heading into the second
half or the climax of the story
for instance this is one of the dragon
ball z namek saga's greatest strengths
within which there isn't really a main
single plot thread we follow but instead
we have the point of view of gohan and
krillin vegeta frieza and secondary
enemies that make themselves known
and even goku and the reason why i enjoy
this as much as i do
is partially down to what it offers the
story in terms of pacing if there's a
boring scene it won't last too long
before we switch to something else but
most importantly
this structure helps to build tension
for when these individual plot threats
eventually start to intertwine and mix
the tension and momentum the story is
afforded is infectious and hard to beat
and that's exactly what this story does
and at points towards the start of this
arc i actually felt myself resonate with
gon
more than i think i have even with luffy
or goku and
maybe it's because i can relate to the
good and the bad traits
of this character he's not perfect and
in fact it's the potential negative
attributes he projects
through his personality that i find
myself resonating with
and that's not something i can say about
many other characters in fiction
now while the portion of the story i'll
be covering today does primarily deal
with kurupika's trials and tribulations
in york new city
the scene that has stayed with me long
after finishing it has to be the opening
section of this arc
when we arrive with gon and kilauea back
at whale island
there's virtually no action to speak of
and while the scenery can be
spectacularly beautiful at times the
only reason i hold this sequence in such
high regard has to be
how it deals with difficult subject
matter something i've come to love about
hunter hunter has been how emotionally
resonant it is as i've mentioned tagashi
isn't afraid to strip away all the pomp
and ceremony
surrounding a particular scene or
scenario or character and he just
allows them to speak openly with each
other chapter 64
is exactly that demonstrating a quiet
moment of intimate and vulnerable
reflection between
two friends and i love it for that why i
love quiet moments like this
is largely due to one prevailing factor
it allows us to see the characters for
who they really are
in as clear a way as possible we see how
similar gone is to kilauea but we also
see how different they are it's cute and
just like the rest of the story there
are some hints of sadness dotted across
the text
showing us how lonely gone is and how
aimless kilowatt can be
one exchange that did stick out in my
mind as particularly sad was when
gon enthusiastically asked if killua
would stick around with him
i assume in gon's mind he would want
that forever and
while killua's response was to the
affirmative it was also delivered with
significantly less enthusiasm and with a
definite deadline
that deadline being once he figures out
what he wants to do with his life
he'll leave and when that day comes i
can only imagine how difficult it will
be for gon to
take that news in addition to that this
opening section on top of being a
stripped down and engaging narrative
it was also quite beautiful in its
depiction of the woods and the star
speckled night sky as the two boys stare
up into it pondering what the future
might hold for them
and if that's not relatable i don't know
what is and
that's not even to make mention of the
role jing plays in these opening
chapters
through various flashbacks and
recollections we learn the little
information gone's aunt
and grandmother know of him and the
means with which he left gone with them
all those years ago as a baby but
interestingly he did leave behind
something specifically
forgone a mysterious box that neither
him nor killua are able to open using
force
thankfully though there is a resolution
to this issue which comes about thanks
to the application of what little
information they have concerning it
jing told mito to give gon the box after
he'd become a hunter
kilowatt interprets this to mean nen and
so gunn uses his name to open the box
and
fly open it most definitely does in
particular a small bit of continuity i
enjoyed from this was how the markings
of the box match the similar markings
that were made on the finger trap
that wing used on gun's finger from the
heavens arena arc only nine could break
it and i thought that was an elegant
solution
jin used to make sure only gon could see
this
once this box opened i felt the scene
shift from still within the realms of a
traditional
shonen series and into something
seriously realistic concerning the
morality of jing
and how that has affected gon as a
character throughout his life
of the three objects left inside this
box they opt to listen to the tape first
and in it jing reiterates
numerous times asking gon if he's sure
he wants to find him and if he doesn't
to turn off the cassette tape i wasn't
sure about this decision first but it
actually ended up to be a really great
narrative choice that receives an
interesting payoff later in the scene
because it gives gon a means with which
to communicate how he feels through
action and
loosely gives him a means with which to
interact with his father for the first
time which becomes
all the more sad and disheartening when
jing reveals that he doesn't want to see
him in actuality he describes himself as
selfish and by all accounts given what
we've learned about him through mito
gone's aunt and his grandma
he seems to be a man driven by something
else that overshadows his
responsibilities as a father a desire
for adventure or
something akin to that perhaps gon
listens to the remainder of jing's
section before eventually being
in no uncertain terms challenged to find
him while he
jing tries to not be found now uh i
don't normally share my personal life in
detail and
that's intentional but this scene felt
as though it was coming from a very
personal and authentic place regarding
tagashi
dealing with concepts themes and
relationships often not explored in this
sort of manga this way
and because of that i felt the
connection with the material that
allowed me to relate personally to gon
in this instance i've mentioned in the
past that this series has felt like
a story trying to convince me that it's
a traditional shonen
all the while the subtle tidbits of
poisons seep through the pages that
ultimately betrayed its true intention
and in this scene the beginning to this
arc we explore that very poison i've
been expecting to come
to the forefront all this time and when
it did i didn't expect it to be so
ruthlessly effective in its telling and
i most certainly didn't see it
reflecting in some meaningful ways
similarities i've experienced with my
own family with all of that said the
real goal of this scene isn't
necessarily what's being said either
though there is some terrific dialogue
exchanged but
what i found to be most interesting was
the subtext of that scene and it's what
isn't being said that subtext that i
connected with on a foundational
emotional level
the zero emotion he refers to jing with
the detached manner in which he listens
and understands jing's message on the
tape it all leads me to believe that gon
doesn't want to connect with his father
or anything like that right now
instead i think he's angry and wishes to
confront him
or worse the tape continues to play and
jing asks again
if gon would like to know who his mother
is without needing to think about it or
to hear the question once more
gon stops the tape and doesn't want to
know who his biological mother
is because as far as he's concerned he
already has a mother in his aunt mito
which i thought was a really nice and
sweet sentiment that harkens back to
what he said at the beginning of this
arc with kilowatt in the forest
however from this my biggest takeaway
has to be gone's reaction to hearing
that his father wants nothing to do with
him
on one hand it's conceivable that jing
is simply saying that but doesn't
genuinely mean it for someone to take
all of these crazy precautions to make
sure
no trail can be left behind concerning
this message dugon if he doesn't want to
meet him
why leave a message at all it's possible
that gohan could have picked up on that
and that's why he continued to listen i
mean
it's not inconceivable he's proven
himself to not be an idiot on a number
of occasions so maybe he doesn't believe
that jing doesn't want to see him or
maybe he has other motivations like i
mentioned above who knows maybe he
resents him and wishes pain onto him
regardless i found this scene to be the
most emotionally resonant and powerful
out of all the chapters i've consumed
thus far
on this journey i don't know how to
exactly feel about it yet but gone seems
motivated so
let's see where that leads us
relax take it easy the flesh collector's
mansion
these couple of chapters give us our
first piece of respite from gun and
kilauea by catching up and focusing on
kuru pika's predicament which ends up
being the focus of the remainder of this
video but
don't worry gone and kilauea still do
some cool stuff so sit tight to be
perfectly honest throughout the hunter
exams and the zoldic family arcs
kurupika did have a couple of
interesting moments but
nothing that would have made me a
massive fan of his character and
largely that's down to me not getting to
spend a lot of time with him kilowatt
gon
and lyorio deal with a lot of the story
beats from a comedic and emotional
standpoint which
left kuropika in my mind as the quiet
smart guy and
even in being that i felt like gone was
smarter than him in many instances
this of course was my own mistake in
pigeonholing him like this
as by the time this video's material
completes i was in love with his
character
and delighted he got to lead his very
own story to show us as an
audience what he's made of and spoiler
alert he's made of awesomeness
and well from this point on gong killua
eventually leorio basically go on a much
more lighthearted adventure to find
enough money for the greed island
videotape that will grant further
insight into gone's father's past
kuropika's is wall-to-wall action with a
sort of noir type feel to its scenes as
he gets hired by the mafia to protect a
mob boss's daughter until
it all goes to hell his introduction to
the story begins as he seeks out the
means with which to gain access to york
new city's underground and
auctions this means being a bodyguard
apparently and it's his interview for
this role
that makes up his very first scene as he
participates in a real-life game of
among us
trying to figure out who the imposters
are within the room he resides
thankfully kuropika is a troy heart and
was able to oust them almost
immediately much to the admiration of
his eventual teammates heading into york
new city as september rolls around and
all our main characters converge on the
city
something i will say is that i was
waiting for some sort of big unveiling
of the space
boasting its civilization architecture
customs and culture but
outside of a few flea markets and hotel
rooms we don't see
much of any of this city maybe i'm just
too accustomed to one piece where that
is very much its strength world building
either way
i have no idea what sort of city yorknew
is and
i think that's a shame and shortcoming
from the manga given how much time we're
spending here and how often this area
was mentioned leading up to this arc
admittedly this is a small gripe but it
is one that prevails both in the manga
and the anime on an animation front
kuropika gets some serious shine in this
section too
with almost all of the great animation
and storyboarding beats elevating his
character to heights never seen
by him i'll get into it a little more
later on but god damn
that weird hand chain thing is cool as
hell and even in this scene we just saw
particularly in the 1999 version the
animation we see him perform within
is oh so satisfying it's around this
time we check back in with gone and
kilauea as they
tried to locate the game greed island
online something i honestly find
hilarious about hunter hunter's manga is
how it at random changes from a timeless
story to one that
very clearly betrays its age anytime
something concerning the internet is
brought up togashi feels it necessary to
explain
in detail how it actually works for
those of us reading because let's not
forget
these mangas were published in a time
where the internet wasn't all too
prevalent so
it could be the fact that a lot of
people didn't know what it was or how it
worked
so this is where the magic happens huh
the ground zero personal computing
this can be seen when gone looked up
where killer was home is and
now once again where kilauea explained
how online shopping works
as they look for this universe's
playstation to put the memory card from
his dad
in it appears the game data on the
memory card points to a game exclusive
to hunters called greed island a game
that has only 100 copies available
throughout the world
one which sucks you into its game and
uses nin to function
i like this literal mystery box left
behind by jing not in like an endearing
sense if anything this is sort of a
weird and borderline mentally
manipulative thing to do to your
estranged son but
all of that aside it's exciting to see
what new information unfolds as gone
presses forward towards his ultimate
goal
i also like how we don't get introduced
to any more new characters right off the
bat but instead get reacquainted with
killer's brother that was torturing him
during the zoldic family section
of my last video using this gem of a
character we learn that the game will be
up for auction at none other than
york new city oh yeah it's all coming
together
and interestingly in the manga instead
of the standard chapter titles i've come
to expect from every volume so far
the story of york new city is broken up
into several days from september 1st
until the auction later that week
and so in the remaining section of this
video i will be covering the activity
and chapters in york new city from
september 1st
2nd and 3rd
[Music]
spiders
september 1st september 1st material
contains the single most important event
that drives this arc forward the
massacre
at the auction there are three versions
of this event
offered up to us and truth be told all
but one of them works for me
the event that's depicted is the mafia
squad that coulda peak has been
recruited into
arriving at an auction of interest to
their employer and those delegated to
participate in said auction stand inside
while the others including kuropikas
scope the place out from outside the
massacre that eventually takes place is
meant to act as a surprise and
as an inciting incident and while it is
both of those things
i don't think i liked it all that much
or at least i don't like how it was
handled while it did surprise me it did
so in such a way that made me confused
and
think that i might have missed a page or
two additionally this section of the
manga goes at quite a speedy pace and
while i normally like that
if it does come at the cost of clarity
then that's where i draw the line and
while i was reading this i had tons of
questions in my head like
is this the auction that gone went to
for greed island why were there so much
mafia there and
finally i had no idea who was on
kuropika's team
i didn't know them at all and for that
very reason i felt nothing when they all
died now obviously an easy counter to
that would be
well this is a surprise so it's meant to
leave you off balance just like the
characters were taken off guard
themselves
and to that i say yeah sure but for me
when reading stories what makes
surprises effective in their telling is
how it recontextualizes the events
of that story whether that be in the
past or the future
when those goons revealed themselves
initially i actually wasn't 100
sure who they were and what this would
mean for the story
this remains true in the 99 version of
the narrative also but 2011's adaptation
i honestly thought
made things much more clear and
enjoyable for me in this particular
instance the event has slightly more
telegraphs is much less abrupt and built
up to as we feel the tension rise in the
amphitheater we
get to see the key characters more and
leading up to it we understand their
motivations that
little bit more also and so on this
occasion the 2011 version i thought
allowed this section to breathe a little
more and
i honestly enjoyed that
[Music]
so yeah these guys are the spider troop
and they were initially after the
winnings of the auction hisoka included
and
the fight that ensues is quite brutal
with this dude called uvo
also he's physically the most powerful
of the troop and he plows through the
number one attackers of each of the
mafia's ranks
that is until he runs into kurapika this
chain that kurupika has
is freaking amazing and probably makes
him the most powerful guy
on the side of good if you want to call
it that right now and what's more is
that he gets some of the best lines in
the manga
once he has uvo restrained he says this
ability i will only use on the spiders
its sole purpose is to capture them and
deprive them of their liberty
jeez that's cold-blooded but also it's
great to see new nen types propping up
all over the place and used in such
creative and innovative ways
this one is particularly interesting
because it comes with
conditions conditions that if he breaks
them will lead to him instantly losing
his life
a nice chekhov's gun that i can't wait
to see pop up later on in the story
while it explodes in his face
all the while he has this guy
reprimanded hisoka wants to confront him
about something apparently he wants to
fight the spider head honcho and kill
him which means
kurupika now has an incentive to work
alongside hisoka
the plot thickens september 2nd
okay look i'm sure this has been the day
and the fight you've all been waiting
for me to discuss
in this video gone's arm wrestling
hustle with leorio to get money okay
just kidding
while that was super fun and gave a lot
of opportunities for comedic moments
with an interaction that was pretty
intense
kudupika vs uvo is easily the main event
of this section this fight here is a
terrific example of how to toe the line
of awesome
and emotion kurapika throughout this arc
has been struggling with his emotions
and keeping himself in check
sometimes even going as far as to
require the aid of friends along the way
this achieves two things narratively it
helps to communicate how much he yearns
to enact revenge
and it helps us see that kurupika
doesn't enjoy this feeling he has
treating it almost like a bandage he
needs to rip off quickly
with one of the most telling moments in
this fight being that of its ending
faced with the stubborn and ruthless uvo
unyielding to his demands to give him
information regarding his allies
kurepika is forced to kill him
in cold blood and instead of leaving him
in a heap on the floor
like his family has been left by this
person kurupika
takes the time to dig him a grave on his
own
highlighting for us the difference in
these two warriors turned killers
kurupika has blood in his hands but just
like the hunter exams
we know he didn't find joy in what he
felt like he had to do
in this fight and this moment and what a
fight it is in all versions of this
story from the manga to 99 to even 2011
with the latter two producing some of
the best animated sequences from each
version respectively 99 in particular
has some terrific
storyboarding with some unreal use of
color in places
and in the interest of being fair
because i praised 2011 earlier
on this occasion between the two anime
versions of the fight something i
noticed while watching them was that the
99's interpretation with its solemn
and bleak soundtracks seem to be more in
line with the characters and tone of the
narrative i think
while 2011's version seems to be more
a little more on the hype train with the
audience the hype surrounding the fight
and occasion in the 2011 version grants
it music that befits the high-paced
action yes
but this however does not serve the
scene or story
and instead works against it in some
respects in 1999's anime adaptation the
music is subdued and somber by design
as i think it ought to be made all the
more obvious by kuropika's laments
towards its conclusion as he admits to
his hatred for pain
and suffering this entire conflict is
one he loathes and hates to participate
within but he feels emotionally
conflicted and dragged into these
altercations due to the heinous actions
of others that slaughtered his family
from a fictional lore standpoint this
fight introduces me to possible
strategies different nen users have when
facing off against enhancers and
conjurers with kuropika's strat being
well getting all the powers i guess
yeah all the powers as long as he has
the scarlet eyes and sticks to the rules
of the chains that he conjured up
then he is pretty much a master that
wields the max power of
all the different nen types as a
specialist this seems to me at least
massively overpowered but let's see how
this one goes as kurapika walks as a god
exacting judgment over those who wronged
him
and so really in theory right now the
intrigue for me comes not from the
question
can kurupika pull this off but instead
how are the spider troop going to deal
with this powerhouse of a blonde guy
september 3rd so gone sells his hunter
license
uh excuse me yeah okay so this kid's
only mission it seems quite literally is
to find his father this license means
nothing to him despite everything he
went through to get it
and i kind of loved that decision from a
character writing point of view
gone is single-minded in his goal and
will not
deviate again hearkening back to his
lack of hesitancy and assuredness
when it came to the cassette tape left
behind by jing throughout this entire
subplot with gong kilauea
and eventually lyorio we follow them as
they try in earnest to make as much
money as possible so that they can
participate in the greed island video
game auction that now
takes place in just three days they've
tried going about raising the money in
ethical ways by
trying to buy and resell stuff and
they've even tried
hustling for an entire day i'm wrestling
to their heart's content
but alas they still fall far short of
their initial goal
thankfully however this is where their
plot thread starts to pick up some steam
tagashi needed to find a way for them to
earn some decent money and so in
addition to gone selling his license
he came up with i think a brilliant plan
for the boys to use their nan to find
products of interest
in the flea market and sell them on for
significantly greater profits
and it works i love this idea because it
proves how versatile ned
is as a mechanic and it leads them down
this path where they will meet
this gentleman now interestingly this
appraiser
he makes note of something i've realized
already about gone
if you recall back to my video
concerning killer was murder of another
man during the hunter exams i'm used
curiously over how
gunn didn't pay that heinous murder of
an innocent man
any attention really whatsoever similar
to kilauea
in that moment gon doesn't care if he
the appraiser has a shady past and
he ignores all the negatives associated
with it it's just curiosity and the
appraiser notices this specifically
saying i couldn't figure out why this
kid intrigued me but i have an idea
he isn't concerned with whether
something is good or bad
he's walking a fine line now
that's a really interesting and sort of
reserved way of saying that
gone isn't really concerned with
morality and it's that very choice
takashi made to imbue a young character
like that with this poison that made
this character
gone so terrific i think at a glance
choices like this can be passed off as
gone being a naive or
innocent 12 year old kid which he is but
in reality he's proven himself to us to
be much more contemplative and cunning
than perhaps any other character in this
story which may very well be a
breadcrumb pointing us the audience in
the clear direction
gone is heading down there are tons of
conflicting thoughts swirling around in
my head concerning gone and kilowatt to
be honest
on one hand i love them as characters
but on the other they have very
very clear issues stemming from their
family that i know will manifest in some
explosive ways down the line and
these breadcrumbs are the hints leading
to that eventual
moment and now it's time for those plot
threads to converge
kuropika now in pursuit of the remaining
spider troop forces
and gone's crew now looking to apprehend
them for the reward money there's this
great scene that pops up as gun and
killer work discuss how best to go about
this
once they get their eyes on their
targets it's really awesome getting to
see killer with surveillance or
assassin's sensibilities color the
choices made in these scenes and it's
also pretty funny seeing how bad leorio
and gone
are at trying to look natural but
interestingly
and we knew this already gone is
incredible at stalking someone
made obvious during the hunter exams
with hisoka now what makes this scene
all the more tense as we build towards
this choice they make is that killup
remarks even his
father had trouble with this spider
troupe and unbeknownst to either of the
boys
is being called into action once again
to apprehend them by the mob after what
they pulled in the auction on september
1st
again building off of that golden killer
will stalk their two spider troop
targets
until they reach some abandoned building
where
okay i hate to do this but this is where
i'm gonna have to leave this review off
on a crazy cliffhanger that i honestly
can't wait to get back to reading this
week
and review for you all next thursday
when i finish york new city
remember if you like these videos don't
forget to leave a like and if you want
to keep up with this series and never
miss an
episode be sure to subscribe and hit
that bell icon now
i don't normally mention that so i
thought i'd give it a go this one's off
and besides you won't want to miss next
week when i review and finish one of
hunter hunter's most
famous and fan favorite arcs york new
city's second half see you all there
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign